[Musique]
tiens joyeux anniversaire
fallait pas qu'est ce que c'est c'est
une surprise
où as tu eu parfois un super merci
beaucoup plus que je te fais maintenant
c'est pas très tactile
tu sais bien ah oui c'est vrai donc si
moi je voulais à chaque fois j'ai
quelque chose à dire mais c'est pas
facile
bah tu sais bien que tu veux tout en
feintes et ma soeur quoi ya pas de
secret ça fait longtemps que je veux
t'en parler et je sais c'est benoît
c'est ça ce que je sens qu'en ce moment
il a plus trop envie de me voir j'ai dit
un truc qu'il fallait pas où louis mais
non c'est manu vrai parce que la
dernière fois on a eu un petit débat
politique assez houleux je te cache pas
tu me connais et j'ai senti tu sais
qu'il n'était pas honnête a senti non
mais faut que tu me dis bien parce que
tu sais moi je sais me remettre en
question et j'ai l'impression qu'en ce
moment tout le monde me tournait plus de
la gueule
voilà je sais c'est pas facile à
entendre mais tu sens vraiment très très
très très mauvais de la bouche
j'ai commandé une hauteur non ça sert à
rien louise le serveur ne reviendra pas
il reviendra jamais et maintenant tu
sais pourquoi tout on être tout encore
tes yeux tes cheveux tes pieds ta bouche
même des coudes plus de la gueule
il y avait des fleurs sur cette table
regarde with l onf années depuis que tu
es là tu t'es pas demander pourquoi t'as
jamais été piqué par un moustique
il meurt louise les moustiques meurent
ils le savent et c'est pour ça qu'ils ne
s'approcheront jamais ta commande à des
huîtres regarde un peu elle fuit les
huîtres ont peur de toi
tant qu'on y est il faut que je t'avoue
quelque chose maman n'est pas morte
non c'est juste que son médecin lui
ordonner ne plus jamais approcher parce
que ses jours étaient comptés il fallait
trouver une solution non mais oui c'est
ouf regardes tu pue tellement de la
gueule que ton nom peut la voir quoi tu
pue de la gueule louise tu comprends ça
tout le monde le sait tout le monde le
sent c'est pénible
[Musique]
attendez on n'a fait que sans ce matelas
sont tous bien
[Musique]
chaque année la mauvaise haleine isole
des milliers de personnes
si vous avez vu ou côtoyé un de ces
individus mais que vous n'avez pas su
lui dire
montrez-lui cette vidéo
des vies sont en jeu
[Musique]